Chad you say you have a film school
degree video production yes okay so all
fear or other you know alumni from your
school are they all working in the field
or did they imagined even to them uh you
know there's some classmates not
classmates because it was a it was a
video production also graphic design so
they mostly went into perfect design
which I still I have some experience in
but like all the the art for the show is
done by me oh okay like the logo and the
post journalist but um yeah they mostly
went into graphic design so when you
were in school them did they did a lot
of your classmates think that they were
going to some male transition into film
was that a goal of theirs uh no it
wasn't it was a scratch on his own him I
was mostly the one that just sort of I
want to go in that area he did yeah they
had that portion of the school for video
production and that's what I really you
know when towards ya yeah where you are
did you do the theater yeah yeah um
graduate with a degree in theatre from
the University of Maryland oh right okay
sort of put all my eggs in that basket
and and same thing for you do you notice
that a lot of people that you went to
school with are either out here or a new
york chicago or something you know um no
not a lot i mean really i feii you know
I can make up some statistics but i can
tell you off hand there's a handful of
people that I know from my particular
college that are in LA some did theater
but they did it in the crew capacity and
so there you know getting into the
directors guild or whatever other people
they are successful and you can see them
on TV that people took the new yorker
out and they actually 1901 guy who he
wrote a musical then it was on Broadway
unfortunately didn't do very well so it
was only a Broadway for like a week but
still it was on Broadway but most of
them they don't know mmm they're not
here they're not anywhere they just sort
of did it they try
then they are teaching you're working in
a office somewhere I guess yeah let's
sort what happens is that you know it's
the easy thing to get into an a hard
thing to persist with so yeah do you
think it's really just the money in the
stability that changes people's course
like that because I know a lot of people
to that have incredible degrees I think
it's dr try yeah cuz you really gotta if
you're gonna make anything you just got
to have that drive to push it regardless
you know get anything of any setbacks
you just I mean we had some setbacks on
the set of the first season and it was
just one of those things where I knew I
was just going to get it done and you
just have to get it done you know yeah
we have to want something bad enough and
I think that it's easy to to think you
want something it's really hard to want
something and I think whether it's in
performance or introduction or design or
anything creative going through the
steps when you're young and trying to
learn and going through the institution
you're enamored with the idea of
something but then when you actually
have to get your hands in it you're like
oh this is so much harder than I thought
it got me I want to do this instead
because I just show up and punch a clock
and then I I can live you get your
stipend yeah so it's it's much easier
for a lot of people to sort of you know
and then this disillusionment along the
way and things and then so I'm sure
there's a lot of factors yeah I think I
think drive is it drives me and you
think that drive comes from being really
hungry for stuff like I know the people
that I know maybe they just weren't
hungry enough because things were do
comfortable for them yeah I think that
could be a factor sure that's yeah I
think it's you actually said something
to me the other day I'm gonna paraphrase
it but new plan remember but you're
saying that I was saying I couldn't
believe what Chad does with himself
because he's so busy with everything
going on his life but he persists to
make things happen and do things and he
said something to the extent well I just
can't stand not doing something that's a
great example of it just like you know
if you can't it's the cliche thing but
if you can't see yourself doing
something else that's pretty good
indicator because that you know you know
what you need to do so it's those things
like that sums it up for me yeah what he
said well I'm intrigued by that because
our unit type that can't fall asleep if
something's not right dominant to-do
list or oh you have that same problem
like um I'll go to to sleep i'll try and
ghostly and i think of two or three
things I'm like all right I get up and I
go and I either jot down the idea so I
remember for tomorrow or it's just
always working there's something it's
it's a curse and a blessing right
because it's hard to shut it off but
they're due also get stuff done yeah
exactly
you